Christina Applegate not holding back
I can't even I can't even begin to tell
you the actress who's been diagnosed
with multiple sclerosis is slamming
Candace Owens controversial opinion over
an ad campaign targeting those with
limited Mobility Christina called out
the conservative commentator on Twitter
quote woke to see the most horrifying
thing this Candace person making
comments about companies who see we need
help it's gross the comments in question
from this clip of Candace's daily wire
talk series that's been making its
rounds on the internet really that's all
I'm gonna say is really I don't I don't
really understand how far we're going to
take this inclusivity thing I really
don't get it I don't know and if I'm
wrong again educate me and say I just
want to be educated in the comments in
the video Candace critiques Kim
Kardashian's shapewear brand for its
adapted clothing ad featuring a model in
a wheelchair if people that are in
wheelchairs were thinking as they were
looking around like you know what really
upsets me that I've never seen a bra and
underwear advertise eyes with a girl in
a wheelchair why did they do this I
don't know I don't know why this needed
to be done I'm just getting tired of
this all inclusivity thing it seems
ridiculous look I assumed that people
that were in wheelchairs also have to
buy bras they have to buy underwear I
it's just something that I just assumed
that was a thing I didn't know that we
had to see that in our face yeah
Christina didn't take too kindly to
those words and when it comes to the
rights of the disabled she's not afraid
to speak her mind in a follow-up tweet
Christina directly addresses Candace
quote do you know when you have seen
pictures of me how hard it was to get my
clothes on a team has to help me so I'm
excited for accessibility clothing for
me and my community hope you wait as for
Candace by the way I think people in
wheelchairs will back me up on this I
think they're on my side I think they
think this is stupid let's let's all
just agree today on Tuesday to stop
being stupid and in an attempt to show
more compassion for Candace Christina
admits there's no rage but if Candace
was open to speaking with her on the
subject she will not come with anger but
with love just talking about it